(audience cheers)
- All right, you guys
ready for Suicide Squad?
(audience cheers)
- Ladies and gentlemen,
the cast of Suicide Squad,
let's get 'em out here!
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- Suicide Squad!
- All right.
- Where are you going?
- Oh man, you're number three.
Hey Jared, you're okay.
- You know what I love?
(audience cheers)
- Yeah, yeah.
- How you doing, good to see you.
- Ah, get over here.
(man cheers)
You'll get fired.
- I love that.
- Yes!
- Just sayin'.
(audience cheers)
- Give it up!
- All right, I love...
(man cheers)
- Goodnight, everybody!
(audience cheers)
(man laughs)
- Ah, there's something, there
would have been something...
(man yells)
(speaker laughs)
- Squad, squad, squad!
- What time?
- Squad!
(man yells)
- Squad, squad, squad!
(audience cheers)
- Don't do it; you can't do it.
You can't do that.